we begin this half-hour with a
controversial roundup wild horses have
long been a feature of the American West
but now hundreds are being removed from
a remote section of Northern California
because as often happens on western
lands they're caught up in the crossfire
of competing interests John Blackstone
has the story the helicopter over a
rocky plateau in Northern California is
doing the work of a modern cowboy
rounding up wild horses ending their
days of running free we are sending 700
animals down to Corral's for adoption
training try and get them homes where
people can use them and ride them Amanda
McAdams supervisor of Modoc National
Forest says she's received thousands of
emails objecting to the roundup removing
horses from the land is going to make it
a better situation for the horses that
remain out there for these horses part
of the reason they're called standing
behind us is they have food and water
they're not having to go searching for
it nearly four thousand wild horses now
live in Modoc National Forest there's
really room for 200 to 400 to exist
healthy in balance with the land the
land where the wild horses live is
called the devil's garden a landscape of
volcanic rocks where the grass is often
over grazed by horses how high should
this be there's some examples around
here where it's probably three or four
inches but there's just no vegetation
left and you can see how they're just
dying out because of over grazing this
land has been closed for use by cattle
ranchers who are now suing the Forest
Service a lot of these areas don't have
cattle on them now and the degradation
is still occurring but the horses have
ardent defenders far from the open range
the American wild horse campaign has
been holding fundraisers fearing some of
the horses will ultimately be
slaughtered in the average markets for
horse meat at auction horses are going
for hundreds of dollars apiece so when
they when the Forest Service says that
they're going to sell them for a dollar
a piece we know they are going to
slaughter
the Forest Service admits some older
horses could be sold for as little as a
dollar and they have no way of knowing
what happens to those animals but even
as the horses are being gathered some
enthusiastic buyers are looking for
animals they would love to adopt you saw
some special ones there today
pretty colors out there
Janie Denis and Catherine have all
adopted wild horses in the past
Catherines was captured at devil's
garden last year and he's four years old
now and he's a great horse I mean I
couldn't ask for a better horse the
horses that are gathered get to go to
homes or there they're hopefully never
in need of anything anymore I'd rather
see them going to homes than starve to
death out on the range cuz they will
it's a controversy that won't end soon
even if the Forest Service brings in a
thousand horses this year as planned
another roundup will be needed next year
for CBS this morning Saturday John
Blackstone Modoc national forests
they're expensive they are really
expensive I came this close to owning a
horse my dad in Compton California of
all places
but yeah they're just the upkeep
tremendous well I hope those horses find
a home I do too